so I'm Brian Smith and the first game
we're gonna analyze who's your name is
hole
that's your last name hu oh okay what's
your first name
Justin and your Jacob for Feeny for fine
okay so a little hard to read this but
okay so II for Justin played and then
Jacob played a six French defense
okay Knight to c3 d5 and d4 so they it
doesn't matter if you go really nice III
and then d4 or that it doesn't really
make any difference
okay Knight f6 Y 25 also Y could go
Bishop g5 okay let's just you know you
guys probably know this Knight F 2d 7f 4
so why it supports the center and it's
gonna bring the knight out behind
keeping e5 guarded in general in this
line white White's allows black to trade
c5 and d4 pawns but keeps e5 as a strong
point for now and d4 will be used by
pieces so as opposed to to the other
strategies first of all you can try to
defend both he 5 and d4 with pawns and
you do that by night 2 u 2 which is a
rare kind of somewhat rare variation but
it's the ideas the new then you can play
see 3 after c5 and then you go f4 and so
now f6 so both all the pawns are
supported and then it becomes a very
sharp game that's that's not the most
common then they've dull the completely
opposite way is to support the pawns
with pieces and when lek attacks them
you trade it off you know and then you
guard let's say and then and then like
this and then when black attacks again
and you trade it off again and now you
try to use the e5 and D for squares for
the pieces so hold two different ways of
approaching the problem of how to how to
keep the center under control one to try
to protect with pawns
keep the pawns there and the other to
trade them off and use the squares for
the pieces and this game why use is the
most popular which is sort of sort of
in-between and it doesn't require this
moving the knight a second time okay c5
so black attacks the pawn chain this is
the key move in the French defense
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop e3 you knew
this right you both knew this theory
yeah this was introduced by boleslav
Sookie think in the 1950s or 40s believe
me I don't know black took actually no
right now the way people play is a lot
is instead of I mean take his fine but a
six and B five expanding right away so
it makes it real dangerous for whites at
Castle queenside like a fight goes Queen
addy to be five castles Queen side c4
and now black is getting a really big
attack on the Queen side b4 and then C 3
is coming next just opening up the Queen
side Queen a5 and all this type of stuff
so if you have any questions be sure to
ask by the way you know I don't want to
just talk and not know if people I'm
standing or some wondering about
something so okay so black played C
takes d4 okay and I takes d4 and now a
six day the main I mean a Bishop c5 is
the most natural moves there's no need
to play a six yet but maybe it doesn't
make a difference let's see a six okay
Queens do too yeah I don't see how it
makes difference really maybe yeah yeah
whatever okay Queen is you too and black
when Bishop e7 I think this is a little
first of all a little passive you need
to create some pressure around d4 Bishop
c5 here White has a space advantage and
you need to be fighting against it now
the idea is like F white castles and
then next black can take with a knight
on d4 and then b5 sometimes take with a
bishop but the ideas and push b5 push
before a5 Bishop a6 and Trey a trade-off
that bishop and meanwhile get an
initiative on the Queen side so like
might might go here and then maybe black
takes it and then goes here and let's
say here here you know what's white can
play different ways but they know this
is the general idea then Bishop a6 so
Knight a 4 is better but that's all in
the whole other you know okay so this
should be 7 I think is a little bit
there should be seven I think is a
little bit
a little bit passive but Bishop e2 now I
would really if I was white I would
Castle queenside I think here with a
bishop on e7 I think it makes sense to
Castle queenside oh yeah you can but
after black castles you have to make a
decision anyway and I don't know if the
bishop belongs on e2 maybe you want to
put it on d3 and you know in some cases
or you leave it at home for a while
until its position is clear so here I
think you know because black loses a lot
of options with the bishop on e7 and
doesn't have as much pressure and okay
so so you win Bishop e2 black castle
White Castle kingside so why is taking a
kind of safe path you know - and another
thing by the way after Bishop e2 or
because Bishop c5 there should be two in
black can do this yeah
that that's a tactic to you know because
Queen h4 check
like if takes Knight takes and Queen h4
so that would win for black but Knight
takes c6 now then then blacked it has
because the bishops hanging right like
us to take on III know if white takes
back black takes on c6 ends up upon so
white has to take on d8 black takes on D
- I know it's a knight is trapped on d8
so blacks Knight needs to go somewhere
like to g6 maybe I mean white needs to
get the night out so take on probably f7
or something like that east 6 f7 y f7
and then got that ending g3 maybe I
don't know whatever I'm not threatened
to take on f4 but in in case why do I
have to play g3 so and it's about equal
yeah something around there maybe black
has this Bishop on c8 but it's gonna get
pressure on the C file and the pawns in
the center can it's hard for a white
think of whites Knight we're on f3 be
another matter but it's gonna take white
time to bring his Knight - to those dark
squares on c3 it doesn't do much maybe
it's better to have gone in 87 doesn't
make a difference
Mike and still has to take somewhere on
these on f7 or e6 though you 6 this time
now the knight can come to c5 so this
doesn't have any interesting stuff but
okay just just for fun that variation
which is why sometimes if people after
Bishop c5 if people want to play quietly
instead of casting Queen side g3 then
you know okay but this should be seven
okay so you went Bishop you to castles
castles again you could Castle queenside
with more sharp and with the bishop on
e7 you have good I think have good
attacking chances
so okay castles Knight takes d4
okay so black yeah I'd like needs to be
64 Bishop c5 so now you see why it was
better to put the Bishop on c5 right
away here it would be black smooth and
you would play b5 you know so now it's
White's up a move Bishop takes e5 any
queen d4 if Queen c7 again instead of f5
here maybe you can do this then because
you need to rearrange your pieces a
bishop on e2 wasn't doing much and the
knight on c3 is and so you can play
knight and and I'm not worried of course
about black taking because what's left
is this Bishop against this Knight and
blacks pawns are in the light squares
and now the C file is open so White's
trying to take that over now f5 is
really dangerous
also and this Knight just dominates over
the bishop dark squares are weak
everywhere as you all understand this is
real important concept and so black
doesn't do that but well yeah also and
then you get the possibility to play b4
and chase the night back it's also
something that could be done okay you
weaken the C file but it might not
matter but anyway I'm gonna continue
with 92 and then at the Knights T 4 or
something like that I know that's one
way to play I guess okay so here but
black played back to d7 right
oh no Queen e7 it I think it's oh you
went to e7 okay well that's not as good
as d7 because now after f5 f6 can come a
tempo and he five pawns not under attack
the Queen c7 we saw we saw Queen Queen
c7 f5 is met by just coming back and I
don't think White has anything here if
I'm just gonna be weak I mean you know
you can take here take and rook takes
its I think you can
probably even take with a king but any
case Knight takes black is fine
White has no attack and e5 is weak but
maybe you can take with a king probably
I don't know there's some some tactics
here then some problems on the back rank
Nene Bishop Queen h4 rook f1 some things
like that could happen but Knight takes
is fine
and what did waited she and I just again
any case black should defend the Kings
side without too much trouble and and
then you know still have okay but Queen
e7 not quite as good cuz f5 now so f5
now win 97 anyway which I I don't think
that black can get away with that but
maybe okay you're threatening to trade
Queens so okay let's see 97 f6 I hear I
would definitely not want to allow the
Queen's rate I mean this is
yeah we're King h1 or something now now
it's change as well okay it's still but
still let's see what happens it looks
like it may be still white white has
some play okay so you took Queen took
back
Bishop f3
yeah
yeah you got a I don't know I would I
would you know kid but should I but
didn't you need to get some counterplay
on the kingside I was I was trying to I
would want to do some okay let's say
takes and something like this but maybe
have five ideas okay whatever okay so so
Bishop of three bit oh okay how about
this how about this
I take I should be three because I
because I don't think the bishop can do
much on f3
so Bishop d3 and this way we're still
we're still not afraid of black taking
that Bishop we were very happy for black
to take that bishop right so this allows
you to get your pieces in in a more
orderly way and
well yeah but you got to look at what's
left it still I am about this one but
this is not good for a white black
center pawns are really strong that's
not good so we'll probably have to take
first on an g7 and then Bishop d3 and
here black can go f6 but then if h7 will
be hanging at the end so and again
taking unto you through so your Bishop
is a decent piece right I mean it's it's
decent but it's it's not like this this
is an incredible piece and his Knight is
his only I mean for now well basically
you just look at and this knight can
start jumping in on the dark squares and
there's nothing to oppose it like 92
night f4 and I h5 Knight f6 you can
actually get a real attack and you
haven't black has has nothing after that
to control for instance f6 so or let's
say so if you don't if you if you don't
do something work f6 rook f1 blacks tie
down there and then the night starts
coming in if the knight comes to d4 it's
really dominant it's covering the
invasion square on c2 and black can't
just just can't do anything really
meanwhile if f6 then you're trading you
know and and then d4 and now you you
know maybe black will hold I'm not sure
but it's and it's it's not worse for
white as for sure probably waits much
better the bishop is you know you can
create a passed pawn on the Kings side
later and a knight start if you get your
Knight to e5 or c5 or something that
could be great yeah so you don't worry
about him taking so Bishop d3 I think is
a pretty reasonable now you're ready to
defend 97 rook 81 + f6 you can trade and
then take on h7 I don't think your
positions too bad Bishop Bishop here
let's say for instance then you and then
this is the idea start build up threats
rook f1 would check him into the corner
then rook h4 maybe the any of force to
take he'll be forced to take somehow on
d3 so I still and I don't think it said
that cleared here in
they explicitly three so maybe your
decision wasn't too bad two other clean
trade
mm-hmm so okay so let's see what
happened so you now you went Bishop f3
yeah now now you can like it end up with
some strong center clones 297 now I
think White's there's some trouble
probably 97 so it says b4 is that what
wait oh we're sorry it's loud for d7 but
that that's that's the that's what what
it just second
okay so clean see fire cleansing shop f3
yeah there should be seven but actually
you know what what do you do after
ninety seven yeah
yeah okay one oh yeah that so it looks
fine well oh yeah take some in 97 those
still you can go back with your bishop
and I would I would say take on f6
though because he takes f6 now just
develop that pawn on f6 is probably
going to be weak and plus blacks Center
is pretty strong I think that looks
pretty naturally okay so there should be
seven b4 I don't like this move because
really weaknesses on the yeah weaknesses
on the C file so why did you play it
though if you yeah before you make a
move like that you got to be sure they
are winning something you know look what
he's doing
after that so I would say take on g7
first of all so that he doesn't have a
chance to get the center and then now
maybe something like this just you know
bring the rook up to the fourth rank
it's pretty useful there covers a lot of
squares can swing over and create some
threats on the Kings side with d4 okay
so like it's gonna first of all slow
down as b4 push and also maybe you can
swing over it would be nicer to have the
bishop on d3 when you so you can
threaten h7 but you can also get some
ideas like rook d4 rook f4 and Bishop
they tried create threats against f7
force them to go Bishop e8 it's also
some some idea that you could you could
use I don't think it's I still don't
think it looks too bad for white I mean
probably if black had taken on f6 didn't
think like before I think this is pretty
bad for for white because I don't see a
real counter play on the kingside for
right now
like just goes King h8 and only it's not
I don't take as much gonna happen there
and black it's real easy play on the C
file rook c8 b v b4 and just you know
rock-solid center so okay so R okay do
you want okay so but you played before
now I think well let's see what happens
before night a for okay 92 that's
probably good you need to keep that
night to create some threats that's
another idea actually just bringing the
night over like that may be taken and
bring the night over another idea I mean
take on g7 and then 92 rather than
rotated e1 but okay bringing that night
over is a good idea so before maybe for
92 though but this should be 5 though
yeah this should be 5 is a problem so
that's this is what black plate you know
yeah so when you take on a four suddenly
you're you're supposed good Bishop is
much worse than his act is supposed bad
Bishop you know so but this should be
five okay yeah and how position is
really getting like positionally just
the the long-term elements are real bad
for white we're kept - Bishop takes
Knight
Bishop takes Knight Knight c3 I guess I
think it's
okay yeah I mean I was first gonna say
move a rook to the C file no I can't see
this one they should because I think a
five looks interesting after this we
should be three even g6
yeah it is your position is tough but
what would still even without g6 what's
the counter play I'm not worried about
well okay let's g6 is fine now okay g6
rook F I can't read it as a rule yeah
for okay yeah you really need to
concentrate on defense of your Queens
side here I think something like maybe
well first of all I think you have to
play this at some point but I'm worried
about like the reason why I didn't want
to play g6 right away is because I was
thinking but I could play a five and
meet b5 with a four here the white gets
the chance to go a four and then keep
upon on a four which is obviously not
great and probably in the long term
black will win but it looks much worse
if black can get the pawn to a4 and
artificially isolated b5 which is gonna
win and also that pawn becomes dangerous
in its own right so instead of g6 like
for instance this is black did you do
this at some point soon no but I mean
this this move looks pretty it looks
pretty strong right just white or this
pawn structure sort of asked asks for
that move to be played if white if white
takes on e5 you know this ya know why
it's hurting right and if white well I
mean the only other thing is to push but
now what gets the chance to play a four
and this pawn is first of all gonna be
lost at some point if like it's the pawn
to 8th white has to play III I would say
here black it's the pawn to e3 white
stuck permanently with that a to pawn
under attack by the knight and the e3
pawn is gonna be a permanent threat so I
suppose a3 right and now you know now
you build up leisurely value maybe g6 I
mean of course black could have white
could have taken on g7 but it didn't
make a difference in fact it would help
black because then black might play f6
and just really break things open if we
don't have to play g6 you just begin
with something like this and then maybe
rook c5 you know we're not gonna be in a
hurry to take the b5 pawn because we
don't want to trade off this the minor
pieces yet
why chances but it looks real
this looks tough for white okay so in
the game was g6
and white a four would still I mean a
four pawn is also permanently under
attack a little maybe white will have
some rookie three moves after but I yeah
okay
white played Rick f4 you know rook a to
c8 it looks like yeah but why do you use
the rookie at the hey rook
why do you need the rock on f8 I mean
why do you use yeah I mean why I would
personally like if I'm gonna put a first
of all you know the a5 ISKCON is coming
into my thoughts
I might even it might even be better
than what I was saying like to play B
five maybe even now and prepare a five
when white won't be able to push by with
b5 and it probably this pawn on a2 is
just gonna die you know but in any case
I know that like if I do this what does
that rekon FA doing why it's not gonna
checkmate you over there in fact you
probably want to be able to move our
King at some point to the center I would
still use the stroke then in any case
because you don't need that broke on mfa
okay so Rick A to C so why didn't go
Ricky one white went King f2
in 94 check
King III so didn't want to take and yeah
why would why would be much worse there
maybe but maybe he can hold what's so
bad about this
this bond enough six is a huge thing I
mean that's really huge and I was
wanting to avoid that think White's
better here you can sacrifice like the a
to pawn in some cases even and then your
book gets the back rank and he likes
destroyed you know if I could have to
play h5 or something you check King will
go to h7 then wreck f8 and you're
winning the f7 pawn that's a much bigger
deal than black 1982 pawn so 94 I don't
think blacks should do I think black
needs to if we had a rook on yeah on a a
we could play e5 again or B 5 and then a
5 that's 94 doesn't okay so 94 King III
rooks III I think white still stands
pretty well here no a4
Rick
or to see
this is kingi - yeah well that's that's
fine but the King still stands well on
d4 for now you should but what's black
planning here like planning anything
well after king e2 maybe then some stuff
can happen but but what if we just start
pushing here I'm King say what is black
tea now
okay well maybe g4 was more accurate but
suppose I could go back to f2 for now
but okay g4 let's say cuz I'm gonna play
both I don't know just let me look here
okay h 4m h e3
Trixie for
still think White's better and a lot of
these positions like because White's
holding on the queenside and black has
got real problems on the kingside
there's a pond on f6 and ignite if I've
come back to d2 and now each 5 is coming
black ace it plays h5 Ricca 4 and then
later g4 opening the Kings side okay so
he need to look real awkward g5 okay
sure about that
rook f3 rookie for than h5 so into that
so rook f3 I suppose h6 okay
rookie 3 but here why again could play
something does this work I don't know
why rookie thought you wanted to take
his rocker or you'd wanted he wanted to
take the night and but then he was gonna
have to he's gonna have two rooks
threatening you you wanted to trade a
pair of rooks if you're gonna go into
that rook if you're gonna trade the
bishop for a night like this so he took
on c2 now I made an exchange sacrifice
and with a rook on e3 probably it's a
lot more promising then then if he had
done it right away although maybe what
if he did it right away that was might
have been a decent idea just was a
fighting chance does it look pretty
tough for black but I don't know so
after okay so just to see how I went so
you made
did you consider something you stood
better or worse here by the way okay I
mean I mean before this like when you
played could have a okay
but what what happens after this move
yeah how are you how are you winning
though I don't get King b12 check takes
rook f3 so you win drove back to see - I
got a we got it's like 9 o'clock now how
much further this finger okay just a few
more moves will just play through the
rest quickly I spent the whole time when
this is Alton yeah but it was your game
as well so are you
look if 3xc to with h3 okay that doesn't
help you much
but I can understand yeah hey I suppose
try some v5 my phaser
yeah I know
these v6 and repeal these many animals
no I think it's really tough position
okay I rep see to engage us we can use
so like d1 King
I can't tell what is it here I guess
right would be three now with six h2
if rupee three would take sage to
look III can't this I can't read it
rooks accede to it's pretty clearly
there's some an f5 actually sure it's
not King f5 or something which looks
natural okay Trixie - Ricky - Dennis lh5
then says h5 so I think that something's
wrong I can't read the yeah I think that
there's King there's a h5 included
somewhere here because I can definitely
read that but yeah so then yeah then
that's you know whatever so then that
that that's a very good exchange
sacrifice and yeah I mean it's it's
definitely something that the position
asks for a Forex c8 King yeah King e2 is
the you know like first of all don't put
the King on YouTube